congressional democrats grill attorney
general bill barber end up looking
idiotic
joe biden finally condemns violence sort
of and covid begins to tail off in texas
florida and arizona i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben well if you learn nothing else from
watching congressional hearings you
should learn that congress people should
not have control over your life
because they are some of the dumbest
people who have ever walked the earth i
mean it truly is
an incredible thing adam corolla my
friend adam krell the comedian
he's often said that when he was a kid
and he was growing up he would look at
the adults
and he would think to himself they all
must be pretty smart i mean they've got
cars
they've got houses and then he became an
adult and he realized
nope all those adults there just the
same as the kids i was sitting next to
when i was in kindergarten who are
eating their own boogers
and the same holds true of the people
who rule us it turns out that many many
of the people who rule
us are just awful at their jobs and not
just are they awful at their jobs they
are gutless
they are ridiculous and never has that
been more true than a congressional
hearing that happened yesterday
in which congressional democrats went
after attorney general bill barr now
make no mistake
the only reason they were going after
bill barr is because bill barr has
actually been a pretty effective
attorney general
in particular they're angry that bilbar
committed the great sin
of tasking the doj with investigating
the origins of the trump-russia
collusion conspiracism
and he actually allowed people at the
doj to investigate exactly how we spent
two years
and tens of millions of dollars
investigating a topic that ended up
being a giant nothing burger
and it has uncovered some pretty
stunning things about the malfeasance
inside the obama administration their
willingness to press forward
on virtually no evidence toward
prosecutions now bill barr has been
very good on a lot of this stuff you
know it should be noted that bill barr
has also disagreed with president trump
on a wide variety of topics so for
example
president trump was constantly
suggesting that roger stone never should
have gone to jail
bill barton never said that bill barr
said he should go to jail he said he
doesn't deserve nine years in jail
because he's 67 years old and this is
really his first
convictable criminal offense but
president trump ended up hardening roger
stone democrats tried to blame barr
for trump pardoning roger stone so there
are a few things that were going on
yesterday
at this at this ridiculous ridiculous
hearing so they bring up bill barr
because they want to yell at bill barr
the first thing to note is that the
hatred that democrats have for bill barr
is just as strong as the hatred they
have for donald trump which does explain
how donald trump became president of the
united states now a lot of people look
at president trump they go look at this
bulgarian look at this guy had this guy
become president of the united states i
mean
they ran mitt romney in 2012 the epitome
of
class and moderation and then they turn
around they run trump like what the hell
was that and the answer is
when democrats treated mitt romney the
same way they treated trump republicans
were like okay fine we may as well just
go with the guy
who is going to clock them across the
head with a frying pan and
that was underscored again yesterday
when bill barr who is
a long-time republican public official
he served
going all the way back to the reagan
administration and he is just
a normal intelligent republican
conservative when they treated him with
the same exact level of scorn and
insanity that they treat president trump
what that really suggests is that it's
not trump derangement syndrome
it's just conservative derangement
syndrome that any conservative
ticks off the left to such an end that
they will treat them like trump
and this does underscore again the fact
that when trump puts out ads where it's
a picture of his face and he says
they're not after me they're after you
there is some truth to that for a lot of
conservatives for a lot of republicans
they look at how the media and democrats
treat trump and they think that's how
they would treat me too
if i were president of the united states
even if i weren't doing all the crazy
things that trump is doing
okay so barr arrives on capitol hill and
he gives an opening statement and his
opening statement
is pretty good i mean his opening
statement really takes on a couple of
topics he first explains
that the reason he's being called in is
because democrats are angry that he
actually investigated russiagate
and then he went on to explain that the
violence that we've been seeing
around the country is not appropriate
and that police across the country are
not systemically racist so here was
william barr's opening statement
explaining the police are not the main
threat to black americans in today's day
and age
threat to black lives posed by crime on
the streets
is massively greater than any threat
posed by police misconduct
the leading cause of death for young
black males is homicide
every year approximately 7 500 black
americans are
victims of homicide the mass the vast
majority of them
around 90 percent are killed by other
blacks mainly by gunfire
each of those lives matter now that
might be worthy of discussion but nobody
in the left is going to have that
discussion because when they say black
lives matter as we learn from don lemon
they don't mean all black lives matter
they just mean that we don't like the
police
very much so when barr doubled down on
that and he said i don't believe there's
systemic racism in police departments
you could see the smoke start to exit
the democrats ears here was william barr
talking about systemic racism and police
departments
does the trump justice department seek
to end systemic racism
and racism in law enforcement i just
need a yes or no answer
to the extent there is racism in any of
our institutions in this country and the
police
then obviously this administration is
will fully enforce this so you agree
that there may be systemic racism
in in where uh let me continue my line
of questioning don't agree that there's
systemic racism in the police department
specifically generally in this country
okay this was the tenor of the
questioning so democrats would ask a
question
and then as soon as barr would start to
answer the question democrats would leap
in
and say i see i recall my time i reclaim
my time
and john pat horace over commentary
magazine points out that that actually
is not in the procedure okay when you
reclaim your time normally in congress
during a correct congressional hearing
it's because you've ceded your time to
another congress person
and then let's say you want to cut them
off then you reclaim your time you can't
do that from a witness
the whole point of having a witness that
you're calling is to hear from the
witness
but what democrats were there to do is
browbeat barr and by extension
brow beat trump right that's really what
this was about so it's just them acting
like jackasses like boorish jackasses
and in the process justifying violence
it was incredible barr said probably 10
times during this hearing
guys can you just like condemn the fact
that people are trying to burn down
federal courthouses and not a word of it
from democrats democrats just would not
go there
here's william barr saying i don't
understand why can't anybody just say
it's bad to burn down a courthouse
we have the obligation to protect to
protect federal courts and the u.s
marshals specifically
have been given that obligation federal
courts are under attack since when is it
okay
to try to burn down a federal court
if someone went down the street to the
prettiman court here that beautiful
courthouse we have right at the bottom
of the hill
and started breaking windows and firing
industrial-grade fireworks in to start a
fire
throw kerosene balloons in and and start
fires in the court
is that okay is that okay now okay and
the democrat's answer was well
kind of i mean it depends who's doing it
right that's sort of the democratic
answer we'll get to that in just one
moment again
the idea that you should give more power
to congress so that these idiots can run
your life
is beyond me i don't know why in the
world you would we'll talk about this in
one second first
there are a thousand reasons why
protecting your home matters to you
first of all your family lives there
second of all you've expended a lot of
your time and energy and making your
home a home for yourself why exactly
would you leave it vulnerable
to people who may not want to do the
best things to your house this is why
you need ring
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it you
can see and speak to whoever is at your
door from anywhere with video doorbells
you can keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install indoor
and outdoor cams you can protect your
whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system
you can easily install yourself i've
used ring myself for years
and i am deeply invested in my own home
security because
not only my public figure but i got a
lot of kids running around the property
at this point i want to make sure i have
an eye on them so i can tell when my son
is about to
do something that is going to do him
grave bodily injury get a special offer
on the ring welcome kid at ring.com
ben it comes with the bring video
doorbell 3 and chime pro it's the
perfect way to start your ring
experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com
that is ring dot com and slash ben
go check them out right now one of the
great things about ring is
not only can you see who is actually
knocking on your front door
but you can also make sure that you can
just call the cops if it turns out that
it's something that you don't want
happening
ring is creating a safer a safer
neighborhood for you they have
all these apps that you can check to see
what sort of crime has been happening in
your neighborhood so you know what
exactly is going on
go to ring.com and get the ring welcome
kid a special offer
on the ring welcome kit at ring.com
again that comes with the ring of the
video doorbell 3 and the chime pro so
lots of good stuff happening at ring.com
and
go check them out right now okay so
democrats just made assets of themselves
uh i mean it really was it was the most
impressive showing of democratic
self-assery that i've seen since the
kavanaugh hearings during the kavanaugh
hearings when they were all out there
claiming that brett kavanaugh a
respected catholic jurist
of 40 years was actually a gang rapist
that was pretty bad
yesterday was also not particularly good
for the democrats so here is a montage
cut from laura ingram's show yesterday
of democrats insulting bar just over and
over and over like for no reason
like bart comes in and instead of them
just asking him questions they basically
just yell insults at him and then as
soon as he starts to respond they go
i reclaim my time which makes you look
like a ridiculous jerk
here is here is a bunch of democrats
doing this to borrow yesterday
shame on you mr barr can i just say
shame on you you have consistently
undermined democracy undermine the
constitution and undermine the health
safety and well-being of the american
people when you all came here
and brought your top staff you brought
no black people
that sir is systematic racism your
failure to respect the role of peaceful
protest in this country is a disgrace
it's un-american mr barr i just asked
for yes or no so let me just tell you a
quote i'm starting to lose my temper
my time and i control it i introduced
hrest 1032 which would require this
committee to investigate your conduct as
attorney general
and determine whether you should be
impeached there's so much insanity in
that particular montage that we actually
have to break down a few of the pieces
of insanity in that particular montage
and bar is just sitting there
looking at them like there are small
children screaming at him i mean i know
that look on william bar's face because
i've used that look on my own children
when my kids are freaking out about
something incredibly dumb and i'm just
i'm just sitting there like
you've got to be kidding me you've
absolutely got to be kidding me
like come on come on okay so let's break
down a few of the criticisms
that they just dropped on william bard
there so a couple of my favorites
so i i really loved there's a
representative in richmond
where he said you didn't bring any black
staffers which is systemic racism you
heard them say that one we play it again
this clip aid it's pretty fantastic
cedric richmond from louisiana
the one thing that you have in common
with your two predecessors both attorney
general sessions
and attorney general whitaker is that
when you all came here and brought your
top staff
you brought no black people that sir is
systematic racism
that is exactly what john lewis spent
his life
uh fighting and so i would just suggest
uh that actions speak louder than words
and
you should really should keep the name
of the honorable john lewis
out of the department of justice's uh
mao okay that's absurd and disgusting it
is
i mean who are the black staffers that
william butter left behind he's like ah
you're black
stay back here at the doj you don't get
to come because you're black
like what kind of nonsense is this that
is not systematic racism
okay if i brought along top staffers
from daily wire i don't know
exactly what race or sex they would be
i'd have to think about that one i'd
make a list and then whatever they are
they are you think william barr
is sitting around and going well i guess
that you know we need some black
staffers up here so we can show cedric
richmond that we're not systematically
racist
absolute insanity the the other thing
that cedric richmond says there is just
despicable where he says that
that william barr should not be able to
invoke john lewis because john lewis was
about non-violent resistance right
non-violent demonstration and so because
barr had disagreements with lewis
politically that means that you're never
allowed to invoke any of the good things
that he did including his support for
non-violent resistance
absolute craziness absolutely so that
one was a really solid piece from a
democrat here's another one
that was pretty solid so this one got
all sorts of press
representative jayapal she she decided
to go after
bar and this was one of those slay queen
moments she's a democrat premier jayapal
from washington the the internet went
nuts for this so
pramila jayapal went after william barr
the attorney general and she did so by
suggesting that he is
desperately treating violent protest
there's only one problem
her entire story here is just crap it
makes no sense at all but it was all
slay queen and the media are so biased i
mean it was crazy you were seeing
reporters tweeting out fire emojis which
obviously says objective journalism
here's premillary
upon making a fool of herself but the
media cheering her on
when white men with swastikas storm a
government building
with guns there is no need for the
president to quote activate you
because they're getting the president's
personal agenda done but when
black people and people of color protest
police brutality
systemic racism and the president's very
own
lack of response to those critical
issues then you forcibly remove them
with armed federal officers pepper bombs
because they are considered terrorists
by the president
you take an aggressive approach to black
lives matter protests
but not to right-wing extremists
threatening to lynch a governor
if it's for the trumps if it's for the
president's benefit
okay embarrassing like i can't believe
this lady i can't believe this there are
a few things that she just completely
blows here number one
the the anti-lockdown protest which is
what she is talking about there
they were peaceful they did not erupt
into violence number two they happen on
state property
you know who doesn't get to police state
property you know who doesn't the
federal government
that's not the job of william barr
number three you know what's actually
happening in those cities not black
lives matter protesters protesting on
federal property them trying to burn
down federal courthouses
which requires the federal government to
defend it this was a slay queen moment
though because she was mean to bill barr
we live in the stupidest timeline
it's just unbelievably dumb and then you
have representative hank johnson who
once compared jews to termites so he's a
delight
he went after barr he said your opening
statement reads like alex jones
and bar's like what are you what what
are you talking about why did i talk
about
i'm turning the frogs gay like what what
now
here's hank johnson who when he is not
talking about the jews's termites he's
talking about guam tipping over into the
sea
because there are too many people on it
uh here he is one of our wise congress
people
general for your opening statement reads
like it was written by
alex jones or roger stone
do you stand by that statement yes
he doesn't know what he's talking about
because this is all absolute nonsense so
they bring him up and they just yell at
him
and they're they just yell at him i mean
that's the whole thing is they feel good
about themselves because they're just
yelling at him
at one point steve cohen the democrat
from tennessee
he actually accused barr personally of
being responsible for epstein's death
for jeffrey epstein's death
which was pretty entertaining because we
all know it was hillary anyway here was
steve cohen
the democrat from tennessee going after
barr by suggesting that barr
somehow respond it's barr's fault bar
went in there and he strangled jeffrey
epstein to death good stuff democrats
good stuff
you've gone through the fifth amendment
and due process and just negated it
and the tenth amendment which leaves
general policing to the law enforcement
to the state has been forgotten maybe
what happened was your secret police
were poorly trained
just like your bureau of prisons guards
and allowed the most notorious inmate
in our nation's last several years
jeffrey epstein
to conveniently commit suicide sad
sad sad i like that he's he's getting
all mad and his hair is flying all
around like
looks like his wall is sean looking like
over here steve cohen good stuff there
from steve
democrats really did themselves yeoman's
work they looked fantastic but here's
the thing they even extended their
argument beyond william barr's just a
mean bad bad man who's bad and mean
they accused him of murder so that was
pretty solid we'll get to that in just
one second
first if you've been listening to the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my magical helix sleep
mattress it is indeed magical
you know i've been suffering from some
severe exhaustion given the demands of
my schedule lately which means i
treasure my helix sleep mattress
treasure it but it's not just helix
sleep okay they
now have launched something new helix
has they've gone beyond the bedroom
they've started making sofas they just
launched a new company it's called all
form they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped directly to
your door
so what makes an all form sofa really
cool well for starters it's the easiest
way you can customize the sofa using
premium materials and at a fraction of
the cost of traditional stores
you can pick your fabric the sofa color
the color of the legs sofa shape shape
to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home they've got arm chairs
they've got love seats all the way up to
an at sectional you can keep adding to
it
you can build something really amazing
for your home you can start small you
can bolt on more later if you want your
all form sofa to grow and change with
you
when you move they're really durable
which means a lot to me since i have
kids who wreck things
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home with fast free shipping in the
past if you wanted to order a sofa it
could take weeks or even months
to arrive you would need someone to come
and assemble it in your home all form
takes three to seven days to arrive in
the mail and you can assemble it
yourself i have an all form sofa i
picked out a three seat sofa with chase
in the sand color with espresso legs it
is
fan freaking tastic all form is offering
off all orders right now for our
listeners at allform.com again that's
all form
dot com slash ben go check them out
right now all form dot com
slash ben for the magical discount okay
so they also accused william barr murder
so that was good so
he didn't just murder jeffrey epstein
overall he was just he was a murderer
so this is pretty solid stuff here from
a congresswoman in powell
what am i supposed to say to my
constituents
when they ask me if the government has
done everything in its power to protect
their loved ones from dying i would tell
them that managing this kind of thing
requires a lot of uh difficult choices
and weighing different
uh consequences i'm not going to lie and
that is not going to lie to my
consciousness
and the attorney general working
together
they're letting americans die needlessly
because of political reasons is it
permissible for a member of this
committee to accuse the sitting attorney
general of the united
states of murder because that's what we
just heard the members control the time
mr chairman
to say whatever they want what about
rules of decorum
oh no forget decorum rules of decorum
that was one of the republicans going
wait a second you just accused william
bar of murdering people of covid
and that's what happened right the lady
asked him a question the congresswoman
asked him a question
she asks so how should i explain to my
constituents how you make policy and
he's like well you know we take into
account risks and rewards and then we
have to make tough decisions i think i'm
not going to say any of that i'm going
to say
that you went to an old age home and you
smothered grandma with a pillow didn't
you
didn't you you went and you got a vat of
propofol
and you just grabbed the syringe and you
put the propofol in the syringe and you
went up to your own grandfather
and you just jabbed it right in his
jugular didn't you
didn't you democrats really these are
these are the finest among us they're
the finest among us
then when barr attempted to defend
himself there was one point where a
congresswoman was trying to shame him
on obamacare by saying how dare you take
the position on obamacare you do
i have had cancer sir and bar was like i
have two daughters who both have cancer
and she's like shut up you
you're not allowed to talk about your
own stories what do you think you're
doing right now is clip 30.
i have two children who are cancer
survivors so i feel very
strongly about this issue as a matter of
policy and i believe that the
president's made clear
uh that he will ensure that there will
answer my question
will you stop playing politics with
americans healthcare in the middle of a
pandemic
yeah this just i'm sorry it was okay so
this is normal sort of ridiculousness
i'll admit
this is normal right because televised
congressional sessions
are basically just soap boxes for the
congress people to make fools of
themselves
the sort of badgering of the witness
that was something new right that i that
have not really seen to that extent
before
it was it was extraordinarily over the
top but where really got ugly is when
bars started to push back and bar was
saying things like so
can you condemn violence at all like at
all at all
like it's not great that our cities are
on fire right now and democrats like
our cities aren't on fire our cities are
perfect everything is great
everything is great it's like laura
lenny from the truman show everything is
fine
everything's good and here is an ad
inserted into your world
here is jerry nadler yesterday
suggesting that protesters aren't mobs
that there are no mobs the mobs exist
only in william barr's imagination
here is jerry nadler a delusional idiot
you really can't hide behind legal
fictions this time mr barr
it's all out in the open where the
people can see what you are doing for
themselves
the president wants footage for his
campaign ads
and you appear to be serving it up to
him as ordered
in most of these cities the protests had
begun to wind down
before you marched in and confronted the
protesters and the protesters
aren't mobs they are mothers and
veterans
and mayors oh is that what they are um
their mom their mothers and veterans and
mayors who are burning down courthouses
and assaulting people and taking over
areas of city streets
at the behest of the mayors really well
done okay
and it wasn't just nadler okay nedler
you might think that he's an outlying
idiot he in fact is not
it turns out that many many democrats
just kept claiming over and over the
violence we're seeing in our streets is
nothing
it's gone it doesn't exist all in your
imagination
here in fact is a montage of democrats
talking about how these were all
peaceful protests it's all peaceful
protest everything is peaceful mostly
peaceful everything's mostly peaceful
now their definition of mostly peaceful
is supremely fungible these are the same
folks who suggested that tea partiers
were terrorists for the great sin of
holding rallies at which they cleaned up
their own trash
these are the same folks who suggested
that anti-lockdown protesters were
violent
these are the same people who were
deeply concerned when gun owners
descended on the virginia state house in
open carry
and abided by the law and had
non-violent protests and they were like
oh well maybe that's
that's that maybe that's violence maybe
well now they're all like they're
burning things down that's not that's
not violence that's just like
that's just fun guys i mean come on it's
like miniature golf
except the flaming object here's a bunch
of democrats talking about the
peacefulness of the peaceful protests
that are not peaceful
the protesters aren't mobs they are
mothers
and veterans and mayors we've seen
mothers and we've seen veterans who were
peacefully protesting
not threatening the federal courthouse
beaten and gassed the vast majority of
protesters are peaceful
most of the protests have been peaceful
mr barr you know that
you know you know that they've mostly
been peaceful yes and the people who are
peaceful are not the ones being arrested
the ones who are violating curfew and
violating the law and attacking federal
courthouses are the ones who are being
arrested democrats know all of this but
they have a narrative
and the question is what exactly do they
get out of this seriously what do they
get out of attacking
federal and local law enforcement the
answer is they are in so they're in such
thrall to their left and they just
assume
that because trump is president they can
get away with it but i don't think they
can forever i think they can in the
short term
i think they can in the short term this
is why they will they will simply
attack law enforcement which by the way
most americans like law enforcement
but they'll attack law enforcement what
they figure is that for the next few
years at least they've got some running
room here
we'll talk about that in just one second
first did you know that a hacker strikes
every 39 seconds stealing videos
passwords files you name it
they want it now take a second to think
about all the private information you've
got on your computer
and your mobile devices your pictures
videos financial information work files
personal documents
all of it is being targeted every 39
seconds to be more exact so what are you
doing to stop that from happening you
need protection
pcmatic is making that protection happen
for you they know hackers are constantly
striking and attack methods are always
changing that's why pcmatic does it
differently pcmatic protects your
devices by only permitting known
trusted programs to run no matter how
many times the hackers try pcmatic keeps
them out and keeps your information safe
they're the only anti-virus company that
does its development research and
customer support 100 in the united
states you're not going to have to worry
about the chinese government
using your information against you when
it comes to cyber attacks it's not a
matter of if it's just a matter of when
protect yourself right now with pcmatic
they protect macs windows
servers android phones and tablets
pretty much everything get a free month
of protection with the purchase of an
annual license
at pcmatic.com again that's pcmatic.com
keep the bad guys out and your personal
information secure with pcmatic that's
pcmatic.com
go check them out right now okay so what
exactly is in it for democrats in
ripping on the police and ripping on law
enforcement and defending rioters and
looters
they just believe that because trump is
so wildly unpopular they can get away
with it
and they are afraid that their leftist
base will abandon them and attack them
as on the side of the fascist trump it's
amazing how all of politics has has
centralized around this point
it also happens to be true that for
literally decades democrats have been
soft on crime this has been true for a
very long time and when a democrat was
not soft on crime such as joe biden in
now he is retroactively ripped into for
being soft on crime
for being hard on crime rather this is
how you end up with congresswoman named
lofgren
saying yesterday that when there is
police that breaks out in the streets
when there's violence that breaks out in
the streets
zoe lofgren of california full-scale
when she says
that violence breaks out on the streets
you have to blame the police it's the
cops fault
you see the cops who are responding to
the violence they're the ones who are
actually causing the violence
it's one thing to fight crime joint task
forces that involves
the cooperation of state and local
officials
but the governor of oregon and the mayor
of portland
has asked that the federal troops leave
because
the reaction has actually been
uh in in reverse proportion
people are showing up because the troops
are there
and i'd like to say that so many of them
i would say
most of them are uh non-violent
everybody's non-violent it's only the
troops that are causing the problem
it's only the troops i'm old enough to
remember when democrats actually
mouthed support for police and federal
law enforcement now they've just decided
they're done with it
zoe lofgren then continued by saying
that president trump hopes to win by
sending troops to american cities
so she's repeating the nonsense put out
by seattle mayor jenny durkin who
suggested the other day
trump is looking for martial law in
cities that's why he's defending
courthouses here is
representative lofgren yesterday going
after william barr
millions of americans have been infected
tens of thousands are dying and
the president needs to divert from that
failure
and is the playbook the playbook is to
create
the impression that there is violence
that he must send in federal troops
and that the american people should be
afraid
of other americans and trust the
president because he's going to send
all troops to americans
it's not that you're watching the news
and it's not that you're watching the
internet it's not that you've seen
videos of people taking over
large areas of downtown cities no it's
it's all an impression that trump is
creating he has that magical magical
ability so okay at a certain point
william bard had enough of this and
basically the entire democratic show
here was an attempt to shut bar down and
prevent him from talking right we'll ask
you a question
bar will start to answer and then we say
we reclaim our time that didn't stop bar
from getting in a few counts or jabs
so there's one point where one of the
congress people is going after bar and
saying you know even church leaders were
angry that you cleared lafayette square
and bar was like yeah it was that before
or after they they put out the fire at
the church
are you aware that director of the
church that the episcopal archbishop of
washington
and the presiding bishop of the
episcopal church nationally along with
the catholic bishop of the archdiocese
of washington all denounced this police
assault
on the civil rights and civil liberties
of the people did they do that before or
after the fire was put out
well all that all that i know is that
they denounced
what you did that guy
his head so far up his ass that it's
coming out his face again it's
incredible
that's good stuff also some of these
questions
were just so bad so ted deutsch went
after when after barr the representative
from florida
he went after barr and he suggested that
barr had basically gotten roger stone
pardon and bar was like um
that never happened i don't know what
you're talking about the democrats
didn't even bother to do like basic
research before they just started going
after bar
so here's the problem barr actually has
a triple digit iq as
opposed to many of the other members of
congress and so here is an exchange
between deutsche bahn which bar just rex
deutsch
he started on july 31st the first week
he was there he came to raise this issue
i think he started february first right
the first week he was there he came into
your office to raise the issue of
sentencing
um in the interview you did with abc you
said no i don't think he
came that's what you that's what you
told abc news you said that he's talked
to senior staff not you perhaps but he
talked to senior staff
that i don't know you know i think i
speak english i said that before he came
in to see
me i believe he had some conversation
conversation
with the senior staff right okay so bar
kept asking for people to be precise and
democrats just couldn't be precise and
they wouldn't be precise
and so bar just kept being like i'm
speaking like are we speaking this and
the answer is no they're not speaking
the same language bar was trying to
answer questions and democrats were
trying to browbeat them to the point
where nadler actually refused from a
bathroom break in the middle of this
which is just like the biggest ass move
of all time right
i mean bar how old is barbara's got to
be closing in on 70 if he's not 70
already
william barr so that prostate's got to
be going at a certain point here
he's yeah he's exactly 70 years old and
so you know sometimes he got to pee
and he and barbara was like can i have a
bathroom break and now there's like
no you can't i was like what kind of
stupid crap is this
uh here it was your congress at work
could we take a five-minute break mr
chairman no that's a common courtesy
chairman of every witness i i waited 45
an hour for you this morning i haven't
had lunch i'd like to take a five-minute
break mr attorney general
we're we are almost finished we're we're
going to be finished
in a few minutes if otherwise you can we
can certainly take a break
but um you're real classy yeah
it's unbelievable i mean they're just no
we won't take a five-minute break we
won't because you're a bad man
so you won't be allowed to pee also bar
was asked
whether he was a republican or not
they're like you're a republican aren't
you and bar's like uh yeah
um yeah i i am here's representative
scanlon again
a greater repository of stupidity has
never been unearthed than apparently the
house judiciary committee this is solid
stuff here
you said in 2017 that prosecutors who
make political contributions are
identifying fairly strongly with the
political party correct
and in fact you and your wife have
donated over 730 thousand dollars to
republican and conservative candidates
including donations of 58 000 to
republican senators
and senate candidates in the four months
preceding your confirmation
are you surprised i'm a republican
well the media were the media were very
surprised he was the so the media's
treatment of this was perfectly on point
for the media which is
he can just be ripped up and down bar
and he's supposed to sit there and take
it if he doesn't he's a very bad mean
man
he's a very bad terrible mean man this
led a bunch of democrats to go out there
and whine about how barr had
disrespected them
they literally accused him of murder
refused him a bathroom break and
suggested that he killed jeffrey epstein
and then they're like why aren't you
being respectful why aren't you being
respectful and then when you would
answer they'd be like why she's back my
time because you're being disrespectful
sir
a bunch of democrats calling bar
disrespectful for no apparent reason
have you now called for law enforcement
to stop using these chemical irritants
on protesters
yes or no pepper spray yes no
no i think it's a very important uh
non-lethal option
for protesters no foreigners
yes sir america was founded on the
principles of free speech
when people resist law enforcement
they're not peaceful blaming my time
i'm surprised at your lack of respect
for a member of congress
okay well first of all whenever a
congress person does this it's the
biggest
ridicul it's the worst move it's the
worst move remember barbara boxer did
this to a service member at one point
call me senator don't call me miz call
me senator
uh i'm surprised your lack of respect
for a congress person he's the attorney
general of the united states where is it
where's your respect for him
i mean that is a that is a congressional
approved appointment right there
and you represent like some district
somewhere yeah i have tons of respect
for you ooh
you're a congress person ooh i know
enough congress people to know that they
don't deserve a lot of respect okay
i know of congress people personally to
know that they don't deserve tons of
respect
in just a second we'll get to the media
treatment of this which is predictably
awful i mean it's predictably awful and
and we'll get to also the question of
again why are democrats going along
with the violence and the looting and
joe biden
put out a statement kind of condemning
the violence kind of condemning it but
mostly it was just about trump he's
trying to walk that middle line we'll
get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that
you really don't want to be going to an
auto parts store right now instead why
wouldn't you get the auto parts you need
online using the interwebs i know it's
an amazing thing this is why you should
be using rockauto.com
it's much easier than walking into a
store and someone's demanding quick
answers to things like is your odyssey
an
lx or an ex and then they just have to
order the part online anyways you have
to wait for it because there are lots of
types of cars and
you can't keep everything stocked and
they overcharge you because they're
charging you rather than charging a
professional rocklautter.com
okay it's a family business they serve
auto parts customers online they've been
doing it for 20 years head on over to
rockauto.com shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts
the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
head on over to rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you go check them out right
now rockauto.com right now write shapiro
on that here how did you hear about
usbox
so they know that we sent you alrighty
we'll get back to
the full-scale media insanity their
reaction to this congressional hearing
was look at these beautiful wonderful
democrats and look at that mean man bill
barr
there's this sort of gaslighting you
wonder why people have lost their faith
in major american institutions
i think we know the answer to that we'll
get to that in a second first if you
haven't heard by now my new book how to
destroy america in three easy steps it's
officially on sale
you've probably heard about it because
it was the number two bestselling book
in america on amazon
this week and we are just waiting for
the new york times rankings come out
it's going to be near the top of those
charts as well the book covers the
disintegrationist philosophy of the
united states
that is to make real social progress the
entire american system has to be
dissolved and replaced with a quote
unquote more equal system a government
top-down tyrannical system
you can see the narrative playing out in
real time before our eyes in major
cities and in congress how to destroy
america in three easy steps it details
how this garbage disintegrationist
worldview has gained cultural ground so
quickly why it's so
why it's so seductive you can get your
copy at amazon or barnes noble and if
you like the book
please hop in and leave a five star
review that keeps it higher on the chart
so more people see it
enjoy also 2020. it's been a wild year
has it not
i mean trump was impeached this year
bernie sanders was leading the
presidential race
this year and the leftist media they
just continue to lie to you as we'll
talk about in just one minute when you
can't get the real story you have to go
outside the spin
and get the facts so if you're a
political junkie set i'm getting both
sides of the story get a reader's pass
today from dailywire.com you get access
to exclusive op-eds from us
your podcast hosts as well as guest
writers and in-depth analysis from our
daily wire reporters
on top of regular breaking news i have a
brand new article today
out about the democratic attempt to spin
violent
writing and looting as quote-unquote
mostly peaceful this membership to our
reader's past it's already a bargain at
three bucks a month if you join today
you get that first month for 99 cents
you also get access to our mobile app
you receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content
and you get to join the community of
daily wire members actively commenting
and discussing our content
with each other that's mobile ad free
access to all the daily wire news
exclusive op-eds
all our podcasts on our mobile app all
for the low price of one dollar and best
of all your dollars are getting you the
left the news you need without all
the leftist nonsense so head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe join today
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so the media responded to all of this
with sheer
gusto and joy with regards to the
democrats and pure rage at william barr
for the great sin
of being existent so this led chuck todd
very objective chuck todd just
journalism all over the place just
getting his journalism everywhere
here is chuck todd saying he was very
surprised at how partisan bar was
how harsh in bar was they heard all the
clips people literally accusing the man
of murder
and saying yeah if you talk about your
cancer stricken daughters that's bad
we're not going to let you do that
here's shrek typing yeah but william
barr responded that means he's a
partisan
i've been surprised at how comfortable
bill barr is playing a partisan
and i say it this way he you know wants
to
you know he lets miss statements go if
they're from allies he corrects
misstatements on the left
he had an an odd view of testing somehow
blaming barack obama and the cdc
it was it was sort of the type of the
type of answer you'd expect from a
political pundit on a certain cable
channel
not necessarily from the sitting
attorney general oh you know it's
he was being political bar i can't chuck
todd can't believe it eric holder
literally called himself barack obama's
wingman
but attorney general barr is being
political
and then andrea mitchell she came out
and said you know he keeps talking about
violence all these republicans they keep
talking about violence in our streets
that's not happening that's all
selectively edited selectively edited
guys as opposed to when we just show you
the peaceful stuff and not
fireworks flying into the federal
courthouse it's all selectively edited
says andrea mitchell getting her
journalism everywhere as well
ranking republican jim jordan showed a
graphic selectively edited nearly
eight-minute montage
of protests from around the country
which he claimed were anything but
peaceful
including sound bites from democrats
biden and obama
clearly very political and highly edited
oh they're very political and highly
edited as opposed to nbc news
coverage which is apolitical and
non-edited they just show raw footage
from the streets in portland that's
that's what they do perhaps my favorite
example of a media member just
completely botching it is joy reid who
again
iq of a kumquat joy read this this is
not a bright person
also apparently was was hacked years ago
retroactively somebody took a time
machine back to her blog and wrote a
bunch of homophobic stuff anyway
joy reid tweeted out say the whole word
bar what does antifa
stand for spell it out okay i'll do it
for you anti-fascist
now do go on hashtag bar hearing his bar
was going after antifa
you know since they call themselves
anti-fascists that means that they're
anti-fascists like the people's republic
of china it's actually a people's
republic you see
so if you worry about abuses and you
worry about tyranny over there that's
because you're not reading the name it
says write in the name prc
people's republic of china it says right
in the name of north korea that it is a
republic
it literally says it right there so i
don't know what you're complaining about
like tyranny
over there you know the nazis the
national socialist party says right in
the name
socialists so i don't know why you're so
upset about it
like what what what
we deserve a better class of press that
is that is for damn sure meanwhile joe
biden
basically again he's run a fairly
error-free campaign at this point
because
not much has been required of him all he
has to do is not be trump and be
slightly alive
and when i say slightly alive i don't
mean like super alive super alive means
that he's gaffing all over the place
well he needs to be slightly alive like
he has to be able to breathe
somewhat comfortably in and out and
every so often express noise through his
mouth that's pretty much all that is
required for joe biden to win the
election
given all of the the pre-existing
conditions uh in this in this election
so joe biden put out a statement on the
violence finally after some weeks
here was joe biden's statement and it is
demonstrative of just how democrats
see because even joe biden who's the
quote-unquote moderate right right the
guy standing up against the
wild left even joe biden he has to turn
it into a diatribe against trump he
can't just say it's bad that people are
burning down our cities so he says this
quote
i've said from the outset of recent
protests there's no place for
violence and destruction of property
peaceful protesters should be malarkey
protected and arsonists and anarchists
should be prosecuted
local law enforcement can do that when
president obama and i were in office
we protected him so then he fell asleep
the rest of his statement says local law
enforcement can do that when president
obama and i were in office we protected
federal property
which is weird i remember baltimore and
ferguson burning said we were able to do
it without the department of homeland
security
turning into a private militia so now
he's suggesting that law enforcement
agents are a private militia for the
president which they lie
because he's determined to stoke chaos
and division
this can be done today but that wouldn't
help trump's political interests it's
not good for the country but donald
trump doesn't care
his campaign is failing he's looking for
political lifeline this isn't about law
and order it's about a political
strategy to revive a failing campaign
every instinct trump has is to add fuel
to the fire that's the last thing
the last thing we need we need
leadership to calm the waters and lower
the temperature
that's how we will restore peace in the
streets
so um the way you'll restore peace in
the streets is by not getting involved
when they assault federal property
that's how you'll do it and does joe
biden have any idea about like how to
get local law enforcement involved
of course not so basically he says
violence is bad but also i would do
nothing about it
so this is where we now sit we now sit
in a time where the mainstream
democratic party
including the presidential candidate
have basically made the decision that
while they were so they'll sort of
scoff at and tut some of the violence
going on in the streets
they're not going to do anything about
it and they're going to yell if anybody
does do anything about it
which mostly suggests that they're
rooting for the chaos that they kind of
like the chaos
that they're fond of the chaos and
anybody who stands up to the chaos is
sort of
the problem now meanwhile there's a lot
of speculation going on about vidin's vp
candidate because of course that will be
the next president of the united states
everyone
knows that biden is a short-term
proposition if
by some miracle the man is healthy
enough to live through one term
there is there is not going to be a
second i would assume i mean it's it's
very difficult to imagine a man
running for re-election at 83 but in any
case
there's a lot of talk about kamala
harris that talk was exacerbated
yesterday when politico
somehow put up on their website an
announcement that harris had been
selected
it was it was obviously a pre-written
announcement but it didn't matter people
caught on to it
well apparently a lot of biden's allies
are like you shouldn't select kamala
harris which is true by the way
it is true kamala harris is
controversial she says dumb things she's
a bad candidate
joe biden doesn't need kamala harris he
doesn't this bizarre notion that he
needs a black woman on the ticket to
earn black votes
belies everything that happened in the
primaries where kamala harris won zero
votes at all zero votes
and then joe biden won an overwhelming
majority of black votes in the
democratic primaries
he doesn't need kamala harris for this
sort of thing kamal harris doesn't bring
him
anything instead she just becomes the
target of focus
so if he's smart what he will do he's
already suggested he's gonna pick a
black woman
if he's smart what he will do is he'll
pick somebody who's a little bit less
controversial
probably still just as bad right susan
rice is just a terrible terrible person
and susan rice is uh aside from lying
routinely to the american public about
benghazi
susan rice makes bizarre wild political
suggestions on a regular basis
when when benjamin netanyahu spoke in
congress during the obama administration
she suggested that he did so because he
was racist against
against obama i mean she's she's also
radical and crazy but
people don't perceive anything about
susan rice she's sort of nondescript
as opposed to kamala harris people have
very strong feelings about kamala harris
as well they should because she is very
very bad
at being both a senator she's a bad
attorney general the state of california
so a lot of biden's allies are now
pushing against this apparently
according to cnbc
some of biden's allies are waging a
campaign behind the scenes to stop
kamala harris from becoming his vp
this disgruntled group of at least a
dozen biden backers including a few of
his top donors
initiated the move against harris close
to a month ago just before a decision is
expected
many who spoke to cnbc declined to be
named as these efforts have been made in
private
in some cases her foes have taken their
concerns directly to members of biden's
vp search committee led by former
senator chris dodd by the way
it is nuts that kristot is leading up
that team chris dodd
famously had waitress sandwiches with
ted kennedy back in the 1990s
they literally sexually assaulted
waitresses it was described in an
article
it was in gq in the early 1990s
although none of these actions signify
that biden will drop harris from the
list
the movement gives a glimpse into the
effort being waged to derail her
candidacy some remain bitter about her
attacks on biden during primary debates
last year
saying they bring into question her
loyalty to the former vp others argue
she's too ambitious
and will be solely focused on becoming
president herself many of these biden
associates have been pushing
alternatives like val demings from
florida or karen bash from california or
susan rice or
or senator tammy duckworth of illinois
of those people by the way duckworth
would probably be the best pick
simply because her service in the
military has actually lost her legs in
iraq
serving the country it it makes her
politically immune
to a lot of the attacks that have been
leveraged against other democrats
biden said at a press conference tuesday
he will be making his final decision
next week at the time of his remarks he
was holding a set of notes that appeared
to vouch for harris
some people thought that was actually a
bit of a misdirect there are some people
who are saying that
that you know she'd be a bad pick
because she's so opportunistic that of
course is exactly right why didn't you
pick somebody who's comfortable with
honestly those are the people who tend
to to be the
the most effective vps are the people
the president is comfortable with dick
cheney
biden himself obama was pretty
comfortable with biden the same is not
true for kamala harris okay meanwhile
on the coveted front a lot of news about
death in florida the deaths have been
trailing they're a lagging indicator
in florida as they are everywhere else
because the case has spiked pretty
strongly in florida over the past few
weeks
you've seen a spike in deaths that has
followed by about a week and a half to
spike
in cases today florida said that they'd
had about 216 reported deaths so this
didn't all happen today those have been
happening
it was reported you know the reporting
comes in so that's been happening over
the past week
or so florida is total up to about 6 300
deaths
6 35 deaths
california reported 169 deaths as of
yesterday
and uh in texas so about 121 deaths as
of yesterday now
there is some really sort of interesting
data when it comes to
contrasting and comparing states because
the media have been very focused in on
the idea
that florida and arizona and texas
really botched this thing but new york
and new jersey are doing exactly
the right thing you see this being said
over and over and over again
that's not right also there's not a lot
of evidence that california has peaked
yet so while everybody is focusing on
texas and arizona and florida
the evidence tends to show that
hospitalizations are now going down case
diagnosis is actually going down we've
now reached the other side of the hill
for those states california continues to
escalate
but in terms of which states did well
and which states did not
if you look at total cases per 1 million
population
the top five states in terms of total
cases per million population are
louisiana arizona new york florida and
new jersey
in terms of deaths per 1 million
population
for arizona new york florida new jersey
right that provides pretty good
that provides a pretty good sort of
counter arizona
has it 475 deaths per million new york
has
nearly 1700 deaths per million florida
has 295 deaths per million
new jersey had 1787 deaths per million
so for all the talk about how the the
arizonans and the floridas of the world
blew it
their death rate is anywhere from
one-eighth to one-quarter
the death rate in new jersey and new
york so spare me all of the
all the andrew cuomo is a great governor
and ron desantis is a disaster
area that obviously is is simply not
true
okay well we will be back here tomorrow
with much much more
and uh and make sure that you go and
pick up a copy of my new book how to
destroy america in three easy steps it's
soaring up the best-seller charts keep
it going
really appreciate it i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pavel
wydowsky
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
eric swalwell blows hot air bill bar
burns down congress and big tech
is swinging the election for joe biden
check it out on the michael knowles show